bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission
spéciale ce soir un an après les
attentats du 13 novembre à paris et à
scintiller les pires attaques est connue
la france depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale 130 morts plus de 400
blessés et un pays forcément bouleversé
depuis l'état d'urgence est entré en
vigueur engagement citoyen important
également et tensions au sein de la
société française nous allons justement
tenter de comprendre ce qui a changé
depuis ce triste vendredi soir avec
plusieurs invités acteurs de la vie
locale jean luc guislain président de
l'unité locale de la croix rouge saint
quentin en yvelines bonsoir bonsoir
et puis laurent bouvet professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
bonsoir sonne je le disais en
introduction ces attaques les pires
qu'ait connue la france depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale évidemment
les hommages vont se multiplier
pendant le week-end et je veux et vous
commencez à part vous demandez avoue
jean-luc guislain en quoi c'est
important selon vous de commémorer de
façon si importante de telles attaques
sachant que vous vous connaissent
évidemment des personnes qui sont
intervenus sur place par exemple pour
ces personnes-là
en quoi c'est important ça leur permet
aussi de faire le deuil de ce qu'elles
ont pu voir de ces images terribles
ce soir là oui d'une certaine manière
je veux dire que nous nous nous avons
été plus technique dans la proche de
l'opération et du suivi de l'opération
pour trouver des méthodes d'amélioration
de nos systèmes de fonctionnement
mais bien sûr le fait de de commémorer
de de reparler de l'opération permet
peut-être d'évacuer les dernières
petites tensions qui peuvent
éventuellement exister au sein de nos
équipes
oui justement vous avez une quinzaine de
personnes des yvelines qui sont
intervenus le soir du 13 novembre un
camion aussi sur place de lons où les
personnes qui sont intervenus sur place
même si vous le disiez c'était plutôt en
retrait pas forcément en amont dans quel
état d'esprit elles sont aujourd'hui ont
apprécié c'est si on va dire c'est
oublier même si c'est difficile
d'oublier mais je veux dire cia sont
passés à autre chose ou alors il y aura
des traumatismes importants oublier
oublier c'est pas oublier bons coups il
n'y a pas eu de traumatismes trop
important parce que l'accrochage était
intervenu un peu
milieux dispositifs les plus les cas les
plus graves ont été gérés par les
pompiers le samu mousse cela ce sont des
professionnels ils étaient sur place
on est arrivé un petit peu plus en
arrière et donc nous avons traité les
cas les moins graves
donc heureusement ça n'a pas trop
choquer nos bénévoles qui par ailleurs
sont formés pour ça donc ils sont formés
pour ce type d' attaque d'événements
concrètement ben ils somment fille
charlie hebdo depuis l'été ils sont dans
tous les cas formé intervenir dans des
cas d'urgence et d'aidé des cas
d'accident autres nous avions de plus
depuis quelques années mis au point un
plan qu'on avait fait l'acronyme c'est
aramis un plan d'action régional pour
des actions multi sites que je me
souviens plus de la suite bon pour qui
était heureusement nous avions testé
plusieurs fois là le fait de le faire
sur le vif et donc en situation réelle a
montré qu'on avait bien fait de se
préparer et qui restait quelques points
de détails qu'on a pu améliorer depuis
mai on a l'occasion justement d'en
parler de ces nouvelles formations que
vous avez dû probablement faire pour
revenir à ces commémorations ce week-end
forcément on va voir les politiques à
tous les niveaux qu'il est quel est le
rôle selon vous d'un politique dans un
moment pareil un an après ce qui doit se
mettre pas en avant mais en retrait
justement de la croix rouge de ceux qui
sont intervenus ou alors il doit de se
mettre en avant pour peut-être montré
que voilà les politiques sont là et et
rassurer la population comment comment
doit agir un politique dans ces moments
là j'imagine ça doit aussi dépendre de
son niveau de ces débats portant ce
quelle politique on parle et puis je
suis pas certain qu aujourd'hui compte
tenu de la défiance quand même général
vis-à-vis des responsables politiques
jusqu'aux présidents républicains la
part de la population leur rôle soit de
rassurer et de protéger c'est je pense
que c'est un des certainement peut-être
on pourrait dire des échecs par rapport
aux attentats
se sont déroulés quand on a salué les
dernières infos landes le gouvernement
au lendemain des attentats sur la façon
de bouger ça a été fait après charlie
hebdo de manière unanime c'est unanime
ça a été encore fait après le 13
novembre mais ça a commencé à se
dégrader puisque la réponse politique
générale qu'a apporté le président de la
république dans son discours devant le
congrès réuni à versailles a été de
proposer la déchéance de nationalité qui
a divisé très profondément à la fois son
propre camp politique et puis évidemment
créer des tensions avec eux donc il ya
eu une une inadéquation de la réponse
par rapport à ce qui se déroulait et
puis le fait que les attentats se soient
multipliés qu'on a encore eu l'attentât
évidemment du 14 juillet ensuite a alors
qu'il y avait l'état d'urgence à et
diminue la la crédibilité du politique
et des décisions politiques faite pour
protéger les citoyens on peut se dire et
on peut d'abord et avant tout souhaité
et espérer que ça n'arrive jamais mexy
jamais un autre attentat sous une autre
forme se produisait on aurait
certainement pas la même réponse qui a
été unanime après charlie hebdo qu'il
était encore un peu après le 13 devant
mais qu'il était déjà plus souvenez vous
après le 14 juillet on a eu
immédiatement une rencontre une partant
gouvernement voilà de l'opposition qui
mettait en cause deux gouvernements bon
sur est ce qu on aurait pu éviter et
nice
le type dans son camion et c'est un bon
voilà donc faux j'ai du mal à
aujourd'hui à évaluer la manière dont
les politiques peuvent commémorer
peuvent être en avant ou à quelle place
dans une commémoration de ce genre
d'événements contraires aux intérêts
selon vous à se faire plein en tout cas
évidemment à essayer de ne parle
récupérer je crois que ça c'est un
premier élément va voir ce qui va se
passer dans ces commémorations mais à ne
pas récupérer la les ces commémorations
pour des besoins de campagne en étant
alors campagne campagne pour ça c'est ça
la primaire sur par exemple la manière
de se montrer beaucoup plus ferme
vis-à-vis du terrorisme en déployant un
discours de ce type
bon je pense que là il faut qu'ils
devraient être très prudent sur ce plan
donc certainement être un peu en retrait
être parent me voilà parmi leurs
concitoyens plutôt qu'en avant moi je je
je pense qu'il va être assez prudent la
société française est quand même
et quand même à vif vous le dise
allanche notamment après c'est cette
série justement on a vécu après charlie
hebdo certaine unanimité dans la classe
politique
mais si l'élite et progressivement avant
le 14 juillet on a vu des scènes
notamment à 10 oui c'est grave
notamment entre entre les français eux
et entre citoyens usa c'est en soi alors
il ya la situation niçoise qui est très
particulière et moi j'étais avant de
d'être profit si j'ai été dix ans prof à
la fac de nice donc je connais
c'est bien cette ville c'est une ville
où les tensions sont très fortes
tensions sociales avec une extrême
richesse une extrême pauvreté par
exemple c'est des choses qu'on n'oublie
pas ce que la côte d'azur apparaît comme
un peu le lieu pour les retraités riche
si on veut mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça yaya il ya aussi
beaucoup de difficultés sociales
et puis de tension qu'on pourrait
qualifier d'être non raciale si on
emploie le terme un peu technique
c'est-à-dire de d'effectivement
détention ou intercommunautaires mont
joli donc ça existe donc ça c'était
spécifique à nice mais c'est parce que
nice venait aussi comme le troisième
grand attentat si je ne compte que
charlie hebdo et le 13 novembre comme le
3ème jour ouvré y avait eu encore
mohamed megherbi mohamed merah déjà en
2012 et toulouse bon on en est on est on
est on a une série donc là ça venait
comme un attentat c'était un attentat
qui pour la première fois touché
véritablement et ça c'est très
particulier par rapport aux 13 9 ans
mais encore plus par rapport à charlie
hebdo et ce qui s'est passé la suite de
charlie hebdo dans l'hyper cacher le
trail l'attentât du 14 juillet touché
cette foule avec des enfants avec
indistinctement
alors que charlie hebdo l'hyper cacher
c'était des gens particuliers qui
étaient visés les journalistes de
charlie hebdo des juifs et le 13
novembre c'était un mode de vie à ces
parisiens à ces grandes villes de plutôt
de jeunes qui sortent pour aller à des
concerts de musique le bataclan et puis
en terrasse pour manger pour boire c'est
donc c'était très particulier
alors que les attentats qui avaient des
tentes et déjà le 13 novembre au stade
de france qui ont échoué et toucher un
public beaucoup plus vaste et là
évidemment à nice toucher tout le monde
tout le monde s'est senti plus concernés
c'est ce qui a provoqué aussi des
tensions plus forte
c'est très très dur de dire ça est très
dommage ne sont que de se dire que bon
voici c'est pas des journalistes parce
que bon ils ont fait d un journal qui
blasphème selon les critères de la
religion ou des juifs ou simplement bon
des jeunes centre-ville
des bobos qui sortent comme on dit
aujourd'hui et c'est bon là c'est bien
malheureux mais tant pis pour eux ou
moins on peut regarder ça de loin même
si on a été très choquée la réaction
après charlie hebdo et ramasse il y
avait une immense manifestation
notamment à paris mon mail
après nice tout le monde a été touché et
là effectivement tout le monde se dit on
ne peut pas nous protéger quoi voilà
c'est pas juste protéger des
journalistes protégé des juifs pour dgec
on ne peut pas nous protéger tout peut
arriver à tout instant donc ça a
transformé beaucoup plus que le 13
novembre d'une certaine l'alignement des
français sur la capabilité des
politiques à les appartements pense
qu'il ya une décision c'est chez qui
c'est une défiance qui est déjà général
agwai société sur l'économie sur
beaucoup de sujets qui s'est déployée
jusqu'à jusqu'aux questions de sécurité
alors les françaises déchire et puis
derrière les politiques se déchire aussi
est ce que la classe politique ne ment
pas un peu de hauteur dans ces moments
là ou alors est-ce que c'est sergio
aussi politique de l'ue et notamment
dans l'opposition ce qui s'est passé ab
oui manqué de hauteur évidemment en face
et c'est bon en même temps voilà je moi
je suis pas là pour juger ou jetter la
pierre des politiques
évidemment on préférerait une réaction
une réaction avec de la grandeur avec de
l'esprit national
l'idée que bon voilà nous sommes tous
atteints et c' est qu' on pourrait agir
comme ça après le jeu politique c'est
aussi d'essayer de montrer qu'on aurait
fait mieux si on était en poste surtout
par rapport à un pouvoir en l'occurrence
françois hollande qui était déjà
quand même bien bien atteint avant même
cette période d'attentats dans sa dans
sa légitimité dans sa crédibilité
jean-luc destin avant de leur donner la
parole une dernière question est-ce que
dans le monde politique on peut estimer
qu'il ya eu un avant et un après 13
novembre
alors évidemment on a parlé de la
déchéance de nationalité mais sur la
façon d'envisager le les moyens de
lutter contre le terrorisme la sécurité
on voit dans le g d'aujourd'hui c'est
présent partout c'est presque le point
ja oui bon il ya eu l'état d'urgence qui
était reconduit il ya eu la mobilisation
quand même beaucoup plus large que ça
avait été le cas après le rallye hebdo
et l'hyper cacher en janvier 2015 qui
d'un déploiement de l'armée et d'un
déploiement policier beaucoup plus
importants l'appel à une réserve la
constitution il ya eu des mesures qui
ont été prises la proposition de la
déchéance de la nationalité est
évidemment qui en faisait partie
donc il ya eu un changement on pourrait
appeler sa technique en termes de
gestion de la sécurité collective
je pense certainement aussi unis
certains en ont témoigné que ça quand
même bouleversé comme chacun d'entre
nous les responsables politiques c'est à
dire qu'effectivement dans comme les y
voilà et puis en tant que responsable
élu de leurs concitoyens à tous les
niveaux le fait de se retrouver quand
même devant des situations assez
terrible de de se dire voilà les deux
est de savoir qu'on ne peut pas
complètement prévenir et éviter ce genre
d'attentât c'est ça qui est terrible
c'est cette espèce de sentiment sans
doute aussi d'impuissance qui s'ajoute à
beaucoup de d'éléments sur l'impuissance
qui vont avec la défiance des politiques
sur la politique économique sur la
gestion des banlieues sur des voies là
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire vis-à-vis par
exemple de l'europe vis-à-vis de ce
qu'on appelle la crise des migrants etc
comment donc tout ça témoigne d'une
difficulté du politique aussi et là on a
rajouté ce qui est quand même un élément
extrêmement important qui touche on
appelle le régalien le pouvoir régalien
sert la sécurité de des français
qui est touché au coeur avec une
difficulté d'assurer véritablement la
sécurité des françaises je pense que
c'est un élément qui est assez nouveau
avec les attentes jean le guislain du
nouveau il y en a aussi pour vous
j'imagine aussi pour la croix-rouge
depuis depuis les attentats le début des
attentats en janvier 2015 est ce que
vous avez reçu de nouvelles informations
collectées ben oui nous avons amélioré
essayer de former nos bénévoles encore
un peu mieux soit nos secouristes pour
tout ce qui risquait de se produire et
les risques chimiques et autres par
exemple en se disant bon on espère qu'on
n'aura pas besoin mais mieux fermer vous
être prêts à toute éventualité
donc ça c'était une première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que on s'est rendu
compte aussi en cette occasion et quand
je dis on c'est un peu les politiques
que la france était très mal placée en
matière de formation aux premiers
secours
ah ouais autant certains pays ou
nordiques une formation à 90 ou 95 % de
la population sur la gestion de deux
phénomènes le premier sujet sur le
premier secours ça se fait d'ailleurs
quand ça se répand dans pendant les
cours quand on est plus jeunes pendant
ce temps là bas l'éducation de marcolès
l'éducation scène nationale est censé le
faire mais bon avec plaisir dans la
meilleur des cas qu'à un moment les
aidera les pays nordiques badigeon se
sont beaucoup plus concerné donc
participent à des formations sont
volontaires et
et ça va changer ça suffit les attentes
alors on a lu dans la presse que
beaucoup de gens souhaitaient s'engager
au sein de la croix-rouge ce dans la
garde nationale ont changé et ça a
changé
d'une part parce que
à la demande du gouvernement les
pompiers la croix rouge ont mis en place
des formations des petites formations on
a fait des formations succincte mais
dans les casernes de pompiers pendant un
certains nombres de week-end
mois d'octobre et au mois de septembre
nous allons recommencer la ce week-end
je suis ces jeux samedi ou dimanche où
il va y avoir de nouveau des formations
et on a quand même vu une prise de
conscience dans la population qu'il y
avait besoin de faire quelque chose et
le nombre de demandes d'informations sur
les premiers secours a augmenté d'une
manière très très très important mais ce
n'est pas forcément suffisant c'est ce
que vous dites aujourd'hui en cas de
nouvelle attaque on serait pas forcément
là circus plus il ya de personnes qui
sont prêtes à savoir gérer des
situations d'urgence de ce type la plus
on peut espérer que le nombre de morts
ou de blessés qui auront des séquelles
importantes sera réduit
bon on peut pas tout faire dans tous les
cas mais mais certain que si on sait
quels gestes faire ou que juste ne pas
faire quand on en face de toi un an de
soi un blessé ou une personne choquée et
une personne qui kiffent une crise
cardiaque qui quittent ya des
saignements qui a des difficultés de
respect et de respiration c'est
important
plus l'information est d'autant plus
important sur l'aspect je le disais des
français sont venus vous voir au
lendemain des attentats en masquer un
camp et il sait ce qu'on a pu lire dans
la presse canadienne à saint quentin en
yvelines est ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont nous voir
j'aimerais bien faire du bénévolat pour
la croix rouge oui parce que c'est un
homme un afflux de bénévoles un peu plus
important que d'habitude je vais tout à
fait et donc
l'info qu'on puisse les absorber faucon
faux pas sur des surfaces la formation
d'un secouriste de mon nom quand même
donc c'est un peu compliqué à ce que ça
se voit mais bon c'est ça ça va se voir
dans les semaines qui viennent
en tout cas à saint quentin en yvelines
des choses ont changé ou sont en passe
de l'être plusieurs villes ont décidé
d'équiper leur police municipale d'armes
ou de pistolets à impulsion électrique
c'est le cas notamment à
voisins-le-bretonneux reportage objectif
assurer leur sécurité les cinq agents et
bientôt six de la police municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux vont recevoir
d'ici quelques mois une formation pour
l' usage de pistolets à impulsion
électrique
un équipement en plus pour répondre
également aux nouvelles menaces depuis
les attentats par exemple je demande à
mes policiers de faire des fouilles aux
entrées aux entrées des établissements
publics lorsqu'il ya une manifestation
aujourd'hui quelque part ils sont assez
démunis s'il devait être attaqués dans
ce contexte là par exemple comme il
porte l'uniforme c'est vrai que ce sont
des cibles potentielles dans
l'opposition municipale les avis
divergent quant à l'armement des agents
si à gauche jean h estime que la
démarche va trop loin à droite en
revanche les taser sont jugés
insuffisants
un nouveau débat que refuse alexandra
rosetti
ce qui me gêne beaucoup dans les
raisonnements d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
a le sentiment qu'on attend beaucoup
plus de deux missions qui ne sont pas
les leurs pour lesquelles ils ne sont
pas formés
on a une police nationale pour ça on a
des unités spéciales et je pense qu'il
ya une grosse confusion en ce moment
espèce de confusion des genres l'arrivée
des pistolets à impulsion électrique ne
devrait pas être officielle avant fin
2010 est l'installation de 15 nouvelles
caméras de vidéo surveillance est
également prévue laurent bouvet on a
l'impression que les politiques se sont
figés un peu depuis les attentats sur la
question sécuritaire et et que ça manque
parfois un peu de débats de philosophie
il dire sur un peu comment vivre
ensemble alors la sécurité c'est
important c'est assurer la sécurité des
français mais sur le long terme
est ce que vous partagez mon point de
vue est ce qu'il faudrait pas aussi
mettre tout ça au milieu d'un débat pour
voir comment on peut vivre ensemble en
oui bien sûr il ya une préoccupation
relance du débat sur la sécurité qui est
un débat récurrent que le fait d'armer
les polices municipales c'est un débat
qui est très ancien espagne vous même si
évidemment là il ya eu davantage de de
tension et puis des propositions le fait
de aussi que les policiers la police
nationale puisse garder leur armes
dehors de leur service d'un ensemble de
où la doctrine d'emploi de cette arme
sont en débat on l'a vu dans les
mouvements policiers récents et les
demandes qu'ils ont adressé au
gouvernement
donc tout cela évidemment est un élément
qui a pris de l'ampleur depuis la série
d'attentats en revanche pour répondre à
votre question directement sur le
le grand débat autour de ce qu'on
appelle on peut peut-être abusivement le
vivre ensemble aujourd'hui je dirais
qu'il existe mais il existe de manière
beaucoup trop heurter cliver et parfois
totalement surréaliste on se rappelle
les débats sur le burqini s'inquiéter
qui a fait suite d'ailleurs à l'attentât
l'allusion par kino direct mais qui ne
se comprend que localement et de lin de
l'impact qu'a eu sur les gens de la côte
d'azur qui étaient les principaux
participants du 14 juillet à nice du feu
d'artifice avec les touristes qui ont
été profondément encore plus choqué
meurtri sans doute que le le mont le
reste évidemment de la population parce
que il ya il ya une menace était
vraiment leur leur mode de vignes qui
est qui est touché et leur mode de vie
inclut évidemment
qu'est-ce que des définitions qu'est ce
que nous sommes
quel est le commun que ce que nous avons
à faire ensemble est-ce que le l'islam
est compatible ou pas avec 7,7
ces modes de vie avec ce que l'on
souhaite et il ya une partie très forte
on sait que c'est une région il ya un
vote front national très élevé et un
vote pour une droite identitaire très
élevée aussi celle de la terre
d'élection au pas ni spécialement mais
la région de marion maréchal-le pen de
le sait bien donc
et puis de compris dans la droite
classique donc les tension était très
vive autour de ces questions et le
burqini s'explique fallu tout ce débat
de l'été autour du burkini s'est arrêtée
prises par les communes du littoral
azuréen s'explique par cette
particularité et ce qui s'était passé
évidemment 14 juillet après le cette
manière de me poser dans le débat public
la question de caisse qui nous est
commun je préfère cette ce terme à vivre
ensemble parce que l'on sent vous
employez souvent blog vivre ensemble
dont le commun le commun oui le cabinet
urba sur ei
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui nous est
commun qu'est ce que nous avons en
commun qu'est ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ensemble etc
la question se pose objectivement une
question de certains l'appellent une
gestion d'identité en moi je sais pas si
c'est uniquement ça je pense qu'il ya
aussi autre chose mais enfin c'est une
question qui se pose le problème c'est
qu'elle épouse elle est posée traité
disons politiquement de manière
extrêmement aujourd'hui de manière
extrêmement caricaturale de manière très
en ne saisissant de cet enjeu que deux
des aspects extrêmement plaisir aux
scopique avec sous la pression du front
national alors sous la double pression
il faut les électeurs il faut être très
clair à la fois bien sûr d'une montée en
puissance de l'idée d'une idée
identitaire que
la france ne peut pas
être ne peut pas accepter l'islam que
alors sous différentes formes si on
posait dans les sondages est ce que
l'islam est compatible avec les valeurs
de la république et c'est donc ça c'est
une pression qui vient effectivement qui
se pose et qui se démontre au front
national dans une partie de la droite
mais aussi une pression qui vient on l'a
vu avec les attentats en voit avec la
situation géopolitique au moyen-orient
avec le développement de revendication
d'un islam beaucoup plus dur en islam
qui va jusqu'à un islam politique
l'islamisme comme on l'appelle même s'il
faut le distingue et bien sûr du
terrorisme qui sont des revendications
très forte à l'intérieur de l'ensemble
des musulmans français où peu importe
étrangers mais vivant en france
l'enquète récente de l'institut
montaigne a montré que dans cet ensemble
vous aviez presque un tiers les
musulmans qui ont répondu à cette
enquête une enquête assez bien fait sur
le plan méthodologique qui ont répondu
que pour eux les valeurs de leur
religion étaient supérieures aux valeurs
de la république
alors ça veut pas dire qu'ils vont
commettre des attentats évidemment ça
veut pas dire que il y à une menace
qu'il faut les enfermer comme certains
proposent
oui c est vrai le proposer mais ça veut
dire que ça pose une question
ça veut dire que l'école on en parlait
tout à l'heure pour la formation
premiers secours n'a pas fait son
travail en matière de justement
d'éducation à la citoyenneté au commun
ça veut dire qu'il ya là des enjeux
importants et aujourd'hui on peut
simplement constater dans les
propositions du gouvernement et une
réforme du collège
l'année dernière on ne peut on peut
constater où la politique de la ville on
peut constater qu'il ya pas les réponses
à ses questions ou du moins qu'elles ne
sont pas pertinentes elles ne sont pas
suffisantes
et donc quand on fait l'addition tout
cela on snobe tient un débat que moi
personnellement je trouve assez pénible
et à ses vins sur des enjeux qui eux ne
le sont pas jean-luc glisse l'un pour
pour conclure là je m'adresse plus tôt
citoyens sur ce qui vient de dire que
quel est votre point de vue là je
m'adresse forcément aux citoyens disons
que nous avons
des contacts tous les niveaux avec
toutes les populations et les
populations musulmanes sont
régulièrement aussi enfin certaines
familles musulmanes viennent
régulièrement la croix rouge
et si on n'a pas senti quelconque
augmentation de tension de problèmes de
quelque ordre que ce soit mais aussi
parce que volontairement où on a évité
tout tout tout tout risque de problème
moi je dois dire que si pour conclure
mon mon avis de citoyen c'est qu'on
fasse une commémoration pour les
familles qui ont été touchés je peux
comprendre en dehors de ces personnes là
je ne vois pas du tout l'intérêt d'une
commémoration
s'il pas une chose qui dont il faut
profiter pour faire quoi que ce soit
merci messieurs d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo
merci donc à vous deux une émission que
vous pouvez retrouver en replay sur
notre site internet tv fil 78 points
comme bon week-end à tous et à la
semaine prochaine